ewok to princess leia we continue the
may 4th celebration at rogue toys
rocky stopped by to catch up with a
special star wars actress
and she'll tell you how you can do the
same
you know the force is always strong here
rogue toys and tonight
you can celebrate the right way with
julie dolan the voice of princess leia
of rebels
on disney plus but you can also get all
of this
signed you can get swag you can get toys
you can talk you can chat with her i've
been chatting with her she's so much fun
so
i want to get into it okay all right so
princess leia the voice of princess leia
yes on rebels but that wasn't your first
go in the star wars franchise right
right star wars uh
star tours the ride at disneyland and
disney world disney world that was my
first job as leia
and dave filoni heard that and so he
brought me in to audition for rebels
that's incredible that's how hollywood
works and i love that
a lot of networking going on you know
yeah you never thought that you were
gonna
have your voice played at disneyland
that's going to outlive me
right now that'll be there for as long
as they have the ride
that is incredible and now disneyland is
back open so there's that that's oh yeah
that's right that's relevant
okay so let's talk about the rebel show
on disney it's on disney plus you can
watch all the episodes and a lot of the
thing i like about it is a lot of the
young kids are learning about star wars
through star wars rebels now so they're
becoming fans at a young age and i know
their parents love that
yes and our camera guy back there by the
way is a super fan
super star wars fan and he has written a
couple fan questions for you
are you ready for this he wanted to
stump you okay
all right so first we have where was
princess leia born
uh not alderaan uh it was an asteroid uh
paulus massa there we go she got it she
got it lance i'm sorry you didn't stump
her
and then this one might be easy princess
leia's biological father
well it was anakin skywalker who later
became darth vader there we go
all right good job all right so now he
wants to know
will princess leia be making an
appearance in the bad batch which is
another star wars
cartoon well she would be very young so
they might bring in another actress that
sounds like her as a
young or they could audition me and i
could try to sound
very young interesting okay but now that
you're speaking of the voice i want to
hear a little something
in the princess leia voice and you have
to kill her right
general kenobi years ago you served my
father in the clone wars and now he begs
you to help him in his struggle against
the empire
that's all i got oh my gosh that was
beautiful see this is why
this is why you are princess leia all
right julie thank you so much for having
me oh yes come on boys come on down
i'll be here i want everybody to see
you're four to eight come and when you
come
down
say hello and uh you gotta have a cute
little star wars oh yeah
i'm on bb8 all right four to eight pm
here at rogue toys you guys in may the
fourth
be with me with you yes send it back to
you bye thank you rocky by the way
that's the rogue toys on
south rainbow we'll check back in with
rocky during the 4 p.m new cat newscast
and that rogue toys has so many old
school star wars figures
and they've got everything lined up
there for you guys and a bona fide star
wars star there
yeah pretty amazing over